ils travaillent ensemble depuis des mois
mais c'est peut-être la dernière fois
que lyle apprentis prépare des pains au
chocolat avec stéphane le boulanger ce
jeune guinéen sans papiers avaient pu
décrocher l'année dernière un
apprentissage dans ce commerce mais
comme il vient d'avoir 18 ans il doit
maintenant quitter le territoire
français
un véritable scandale pour son patron
l'état casse rencontre
donc il n'est plus on apprend c'est chez
moi il ne fait plus partie du personnel
donc à partir du 3 mois je fais une
grève de la faim il ya un certain mental
donc le tiendrait et pourquoi ça va ça
fasse bouger les lignes
parce que c'est anormal qu'on fasse
partir un gamin qui veut travailler qu a
du potentiel et que nous dans une
profession c'est tellement dur de
trouver des employés que là je perds un
tiers de mon effectif au fournil là il
ne souhaite pas s'exprimer sur sa
situation actuelle
ce qu'il veut bien sûr c'est obtenir son
ca fait de boulanger vu que j'ai pas
trouvé d'apprentissage un plan de ris
j'ai choisi la boulangerie et j'ai fait
un stage en blanc gris quand je cale gré
et l'ag et me lave linge et du coup je
me lève tous les jeux finito donc je te
la journée et là je peux aller à
l'entraînement de foot parce que je fais
du foot aussi à partir du 2 il fait plus
partie d'entreprises déjà et puis
regardez son employé en tout cas
stéphane n'hésite pas à mobiliser ses
clients une pétition a même été lancée
sur internet
si la france continuer à honorer ses
valeurs elle devrait faire quelque chose
pour les gens dans cette situation et
pour d'autres à la je sais sans
exclusive
je pense qu'il ya des choses comme ça
qui doit l'être affirmé je trouve que
monsieur jacquet a beaucoup de courage
tan tan et sa crête de la fin pour nous
mêmes nous réveiller comme il l'a fait
avec la manière cette occasion en
attendant un recours a été déposé pour
permettre aux jeunes hommes de rester en
france et de se construire ici à
besançon une nouvelle vie